bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors lui gtg est entre
autres en à l'origine de cette manie de
cette mobilisation comment vous
positionnez vous par rapport à la
tournure qu'elle est en train de prendre
l'eau bien sûr qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que deux pilotes 17 juillet
effectivement une trentaine
d'organisations a appelé à une
mobilisation générale dans tous les
secteurs d'activité dans toute la
guadeloupe dans la mesure où après
quatre mois de marche pacifique quatre
mois d'un meeting quatre mois d'appels
on a déposé un préavis de grève générale
où on n'a pas été entendu on n'a pas été
pris en compte et bien évidemment
aurait agi et il faut savoir contretemps
malgré les relances concernant la plate
forme de revendications seule réponse
qu'on a eu c'est la répression la
violence crue policière les arrestations
arbitraires c'est tout ce qu'on a eu nos
il faut savoir que ce qui arrive
actuellement lié c'est de la
responsabilité totale et entière de la
représentation politique de l'état
français ils ont toujours répondu par la
violence policière par la répression et
bien évidemment aujourd'hui la seule
chose qu'on met en avant eh ben c'est
les casses c'est les vols justement pour
encore une fois justifié ce que le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé
l'envoi de fonds sao mai
particulièrement le gign et le raid qui
dit encore une fois pour massacrer le
guadeloupéen pour
réprimer les guadeloupéens et dans notre
pays dans notre histoire c'est toujours
la réponse qu'on a eu c'est la
répression au lieu de la discussion au
lieu de la négociation on a toujours la
répression mais il faut savoir que plus
on aura la répression et plus en face la
population va réagir et va répondre la
nuit d'hier soir mais tout ce qui s'est
passé hier soir c'est après la noce
justement du gouvernement de la mise en
place d'un couvre-feu et dans l'envoi de
renforts de forces armées justement ton
soi-disant république rétablir l'ordre
mais voilà la réponse alors il s'agit
uniquement de la provocation et de la
violence policière
vous appelez un à poursuivre la
mobilisation on a lu le communiqué que
vous avez publié hier mais vous appelez
la poursuivre jusqu'à quand on sait
qu'il n'ya une réunion demain avec
notamment jean castex et des élus de
guadeloupe est ce que selon les
conclusions après la réunion de demain
est ce que lui gtg serait prête à lever
l'appel à manifester alors oui on
continue à appeler à la mobilisation on
continue le combat qu'on mène parce que
jusqu'à présent ce sont des milliers de
guadeloupéens qu'ils ont mis à la rue ce
sont des milliers de familles
guadeloupéennes désomais qui sont dans
une situation très précaire et avec ça
en suspens dans l'ensemble du personnel
soignant hospitalisés ou non hospital
les établissements d'hospitalisation ou
pas hébétés les services on sait qu'il
ne fonctionne pas donc depuis cet homme
on dit que le peuple est en danger parce
qu'il n'a pas la possibilité de se faire
soigner
voilà un à violence donc on continue la
mobilisation jusqu'à ce que on est
l'engagement de l'état qui vont répondre
et qui vous met en place des mesures
pour répondre à l'ensemble de la
plateforme négociations qu'on a déposé
depuis le mois de mai voilà ce qui va
faire les effectivement qu'on va sortir
de cette situation de la prise en compte
des revendications qui va permettre
enfin aux guadeloupéens de pouvoir vivre
dans leur pays de pouvoir se soigner
dans leur pays la situation est trop
critique de la misère sociale on ne peut
plus continuer comme ça les gens ne
peuvent plus tenir donc il faut
absolument qu'ils s'asseyent et qui
prennent l'engagement de régler tous les
problèmes qui en guadeloupe alors on le
rappelle en tout est parti d'une
contestation en contre l'obligation
vaccinale des soigneurs contre le pass
sanitaires étaient finalement
aujourd'hui les revendications sont
beaucoup plus là est ce que finalement
la crise sanitaire n'a pas mis en
lumière un finalement les problèmes que
rencontrait déjà les guadeloupéens et
ben justement tout au début c'est vrai
qu'ils avaient la contestation contre
l'obligation vaccinale et coupent pas
sanitaire mais à travers cette
mobilisation et b l'ensemble des jeunes
de guadeloupe et la population à
continuer a dit aucun en quad ou il n'y
a pas que ça ça c'est la goutte d'eau
qui a fait déborder le vase mais il faut
savoir qu'on avait mis en place un
accord en 2009 l'accord bino et l'accord
du 4 mars qui motive normalement est
essentiel régler tous les problèmes en
guadeloupe d'autres sociale économique
et politique mais rien n'a été respectée
donc aujourd'hui la situation a empiré
la situation a empiré et se lavent c'est
normal que finalement on aboutisse à
cette situation de révolte les gens n'en
peuvent plus les gens sont en colère et
les gens ne peuvent plus non aujourd'hui
il est urgent et les temps de régler les
problèmes de s'asseoir et de régler les
problèmes peut te permettre aux
guadeloupéens de vivre dans leur pays
très rapidement maintenant on n'a pas
beaucoup le temps je reviens la réunion
de demain vous en attendez quoi vous
l'avez dit vous êtes prêt vous est
ouverte à la négociation
alors effectivement on entendu parler de
dialogue mais aucun dialogue et pour
savoir que nos organisations qui avons
appelé au mouvement jusqu'à prête
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'a reçu aucune
invitation à négocier nous sommes les
seuls susceptibles de dire ce qu'on veut
puisque nous sommes dans la rue tous les
jours c'est nous qui devons négocier et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'a rien obtenu
non on peut pas parler de dialogue qu'on
peut pas parler de discussions par ce
jusqu'à aujourd'hui personne ne nous a
invités à discuter ou à les copier
merci beaucoup en maïté hubert homme
tout le monde d'avoir répondu à nos
questions de la pac vous êtes secrétaire
général de l'union générale des
travailleurs guadeloupéens un des
syndicats à l'origine de ce mouvement de
contestation mercière